pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale en
1943 les Allemands bombardent le port de
Bari en Italie et il se trouve qu'un des
bateaux touchés contient 60 tonnes d'une
archimique bien connu le gaz moutarde
sauf que personne n'est au courant mais
comme le nombre de morts et de malade
augmente 2 jours en jours un médecin le
docteur Alexander est appelé pour mener
l'enquête il finit par découvrir deux
choses un les victimes ont été exposés
au gaz moutarde donc et de les cellules
présentes dans leur sang et notamment
leur globules blancs sont anormalement
bas des pharmacologues de l'Université
de Yale se penchent sur la question et
découvre que les moutarde azotées
présentes dans le gaz empêche la
multiplication des cellules qui se
divisent rapidement donc de certaines
cellules saines comme celle du sang ou
celle des racines capillaires par
exemple mais aussi des cellules
cancéreuses la chimiothérapie
anticancéreuse